hallo liebe leute wir begrüßen euch
heute aus berlin und wien hallo matthias
ja wir haben uns überlegt wir machen
heute mal ein video von zu hause denn
wir sind gerade beide zu hause
matthias wo bist du bei mir in der küche
in wien in zwei hüte matthias heute
wollen wir mal wieder über das
österreichische deutsch reden und wir
haben in den letzten wochen und monaten
mehrere videos gemacht wo wir deutsch
mit anderen sprachen mit ähnlichen
sprachen verglichen haben zum beispiel
mit niederländisch mit dänisch und das
letzte mal waren wir in der schweiz
schweizerdeutsch ist ja offiziell keine
eigene sprache auch wenn es sehr anders
ist und wir dachten jetzt machen wir mal
so ein video mit dir
gibt es denn überhaupt so etwas wie
österreichisches deutsch
naja wenn wir gerne sorgen würden es
gibt es reichlich gibt es offiziell
keine österreichische sprache und
eigentlich ist das österreichische da
ist ein rechteck sehr ähnlich zum
deutschen geschrieben sogar komplett
gleich aber ausgesprochen relativ anders
das ist interessant weil genau wie die
schweizer lernt ihr in der schule
hochdeutsch ihr seht im fernsehen
meistens hochdeutsch dennoch ihr sprecht
aber dialekt und schreibt auch in der
inoffiziellen sprache zum beispiel beim
chatten dialekt genau
also ich persönlich mache das nicht ich
schreibe meine textnachrichten mit mit
auf hochdeutsch also etwas von mir
geschrieben dieser hochdeutsch genau mit
bisher vor ausnahmen vielleicht bei
privater aber so ganz viele freunde von
mir schreibt amd legt zurück auf
whatsapp oder bemessen
und es gibt ja und das ist ja auch noch
die schwierigkeit es gibt ja nicht ein
österreichisches deutsch sondern
verschiedene dialekte wie viele dialekte
gibt es nennen was sprichst du also wie
viele genau kann ich gar nicht sagen
weil es gibt wirklich sehr viele
österreicher neuen bundesländer und in
jedem der bundesländer
gibt es eigenheiten und manche sind
recht extrem wie in vorarlberg grenze zu
vorarlberg der schweiz und und der
wiener dialekt sondern komplett anders
ich hab an verschiedenen einfluss eben
salzburg oberösterreich weil die ihnen
der gegend aufgewachsen bin und salzburg
oberösterreich hauptmarkt ganz an
ähnlichen intellekt und die wohne jetzt
seit zwölf jahren in wien
und ich hab keinen widerlegt aber
manchmal gibt es aber wörter die aus den
wiener dialekt sozusagen reinkommen wenn
ich wollte ich direkt fragen gibt es so
ein wort würde ich deins
bürgerfreundliche ausmachen ja genau das
werden zwei weitere wieder einfangen das
arme ist es wird nur in salzburg sagt
mal vor dass sagt maffay oder das ist
voll klasse oder hat es ist super und in
wien sagt man dafür uhr das ist douglas
das ist super und so weiteres tool
verwendet wird dann sofort alles sabine
und das zweite wort ist so cool oder
super ich sehe überall gleich auch die
wiener haben ein eigenes wort das ist
leiwand und das ist ziemlich nur in wien
und um grenzen des niederösterreich aber
das wort leiwand für den salzburg
überhaupt neben verwenden gut dann
fangen wir mal an mein erstes wort an
dich guten tag
dann könnte man sagen aber das ist
vielleicht war dazu die rechtmäßig
behaftet sondern vielmehr kulturell in
österreich über rein gibt sagt mal chris
chris kennt genau und wenn jemand
reinkommt unseren guten tag liest man
sofort das ist in süddeutschland in
bayern sind sagt man auch grüß gott
genug also was sagt ihr denn zur hallo
also hallo ist auch möglich aber
österreich ich will man sagen servus
sowie die typische österreichische form
oder christi interessant gut machen wir
mal weiter
ich spreche hochdeutsch spricht wirklich
und oberösterreich
das haus das haus die kartoffel
da wird es wieder interessant entweder
die kartoffel oder der erde will der
erdäpfel es kommt von apfel der erdapfel
und somit dollar an drei artikeln
und wenn ihr am markt geht dann würde
ich eher dafür verlangen und nennt
kartoffeln die möhre
die gruppen also mehr verwendet die
tomate twitter zwar formeln die tomaten
oder die paradeiser also wenn ich in den
supermarkt gehe bei euch in österreich
werden guten tag ich hätte gerne
kartoffeln und tomaten dann hörte ich
bin deutsch genau aber wenn guten tag
die kartoffeln tomaten bis passe das
wird mal wenn wir nicht sofort
identifizieren
spannend wird es auch wieder ändern noch
eines der kompliziertesten tote
kartoffeln und die tomaten rein in die
tüte ja das kommt uns gar nicht in die
tüte
na das wäre uns das sackerl und das ist
für die ärzte der krassesten ist
bereichen worte die die unterscheidung
zwischen österreich und deutschland fort
sichtbar macht kein österreicher würde
ich jemals das täter verwenden man so
hört man sie ist total als deutscher
sofort im supermarkt wie sieht denn aus
mit das brötchen werden sollen
18-mal sma jan erste mal ist bei uns
wirklich nur das rumpel weiß brötchen
habt ihr auch ein märkchen oder einen
kartoffel brötchen deutschland gibt es
viele rädchen nazis nennen wir wickeln
das wäre genau am meer comeback
oder sonnenblumen becker interessant und
das benutzt man in süddeutschland auch
ich glaube beim essen wäre mir jetzt
viele unterschiede gehört bekommt beim
essen gibt es glaube ich die meisten
unterschiede so beise nicht politischen
begriffen oder so schätze ich gibt es
nicht so viele unterschiede oder
politischer so wir haben andere
bezeichnungen oft genau aber beim essen
dieses fiel der markantesten das t shirt
das label ok matthias ich habe jetzt
noch einige ich will das noch einige
unterschiede aufzeigen und habe ein paar
beispiel wörter mitgebracht und zwar wie
sprichst du das wort fertig aus fertig
fertiger genau das zeigt nämlich den
unterschied bei dem gag also das sind so
genannte passive also entsprechend das
ende zum beispiel könig das spreche ich
weich aus könig und können würdest du
das sagen
könig ja da wir immer stimmt stärker
betonen
dann habt ihr auch viele nasale so also
mehr stärkere nasale in den vokalen
glaube ich wie würdest du zum beispiel
krankenkasse oder apfel aussprechen
apfel wer oppel und krankenkasse glaubt
krankenkasse ein bisschen krank heißt
genau ich bin krank das sagen wir krank
zum kong das wäre ihr euch gibt es heute
so es ist kaká und co sondern jetzt
kommen wir zum eu nicht sagt zum
beispiel deutsch ja wir werden ein
bisschen die hitmeister bundestag
leute bleibt heute halb drei wie würdest
du denn so etwas sagen wie geht es dir
wie gehts gar matthias hörst du mich was
machst du heute noch 'was machst halt
nur ich muss zur arbeit
arbeiten oder was hackeln niemals
hackeln hier dann haben wir noch zwei
sätze wie ist es denn mit seid ihr
verrückt
das ist für mich typisch ist ich weiß
schon das wort app hatte werden denke
ich schon an dich ein großer unterschied
besteht auch darin und das sorgt immer
für verwirrung zwischen uns ich sage
hier und du sagst du da wenn ich jetzt
soll ich sage ich bin ihr in berlin
es wird sorgen will ist in wien und wenn
ich jetzt sage du bist da in wien
ich glaube ich habe jetzt nicht
verstanden was du mit du bist die nummer
1 auch entsprechend über mich spricht
für mich also hier ist immer da wo ich
gerade bin da ist an einem anderen ort
wenn ich zum beispiel sagen du bist da
in wien ist sprecher für uns ist alles
doch du bist dort in berlin lebe dein
leben wirklich hast doch total
verwirrend
doch pia und du bist da schlimmer wird
es nur noch bei den folgenden wörtern
hinaus am auf weg hinunter
hinnüber aber hinüber sagen wir gesagt
ich gehe schnell ich gehe schnell rüber
auf die andere straßenseite auf die
andere seite
und wie ist es mit hinein
ich gehe das geschäft hinein geht das
ist etwas was ich gar nicht verstehe und
auch selten gehört habe ich komme aus
dem geschäft heraus
auf sie kommen trifft oder auszahlen je
nach dem geschäft aussah und deshalb
andere ganz starke regionale
unterschiede das ist wieder salzburg
oberösterreich ich doch mal ganz krasse
unterschiede in tirol und vorarlberg so
dass ich hoffe mein verständnis
verstehen kann und das ist voll cool das
ist wirklich cool acryl matthias danke
dass du mit gemacht hast
wir haben jetzt unser fazit ist
österreichische dialekte können sehr
anders klingen und wenn man deutsch
lernt kann es vielleicht auch etwas
überfordert seien am anfang aber in den
großen städten ist der unterschied nicht
denn so groß dass man nicht versteht
oder erstens diesen zweiten jeder
österreicher hochdeutsch eben gesagt
cordes tourist oder als urlauber oder
wenn man nach österreich kommt braucht
mal überhaupt keine angst haben
außerdem seien extrem freundlich und
höfen klima gern aus das kann nicht
bestätigen und ich sage auch schweren
herzens ihr seid freundlicher als wir
deutschen meist schwierig zu vergleichen
es freut mich auf jeden fall dass wir
uns kennen matthias und ich hoffe daher
dass in zukunft noch mal wiederholen
dann folgt uns auch gerne bei instagram
da machen matthias und ich jetzt ab und
an auch live videos und sprechen auch
gerne über die österreichische sprache
und die witzige unterschiede und dann
wenn ihr hochdeutsch lernen wollt und
die aussprache üben wollt dann könnt ihr
auch mal unsere apps edlinger
ausprobieren da könnt ihr nämlich
tatsächlich eure aussprache selber
aufnehmen abspielen und mit der
aussprache eines muttersprachler
vergleichen denn am anfang sollte dir
immer hochdeutsch lernen
auch wenn ihr in wien wohnt oder in
salzburg wo das ist meistens der erste
schritt um dann auch ein bisschen
dialekt zu verstehen und zu können
danke matthias höhn wir posten nach
unten links wo die leute dir folgen
können wo geht das bei machen